Okay.
Let's go next to our caller from the two five,
three area code.
Who's calling today from two five three.
Okay.
Hey David, it's a gym and I just wanted to
say a longtime listener.
First time caller.
Love Ya.
And I just wanted to talk about the green
new deal and just see what ideas you had about
maybe getting that pushed through.
And also I'm a guy I despise came up on my
youtube the other day on a commercial Gavin
McInnes on this new show free speech and I
was trying to click out of it right away and
then all of a sudden I saw Dr Cornell West
and Mark Lamont Hill on the show and I actually
checked it out.
And um, it's a cool show in regards to just
liberals nailing, uh, Gavin.
And it was so awesome to watch, especially
Marc Lamont Hill.
I canceled my subscription because I saw all
the shows, but I just thought it'd be awesome
if you could get on his show and destroy him.
So hold on.
You canceled your subscription to what?
Oh, I signed up just to wash the doctor Lamont
Hill.
Oh, I see.
I see.
I will have something to say personally that
I'm involved with the, that affects me with
regard to this new Gavin McInnes show at some
point soon.
Like I don't, I don't, I can't talk about
it yet, but I'm going have something to talk
about related to it because I've had like
a personal, uh, um, run in with this program
and, uh, I think it'll be an interesting story
as far as the green new deal, listen to the,
the green new deal is a broad framework.
So when you say pushing it through, I mean,
listen, right now it's not going anywhere.
Republicans control the Senate.
Um, I think that there's lots of good ideas
and the green new deal, we interviewed one
of the architects of the green new deal on
the program a couple of months ago.
I guess it was a, but as it is, even if it
passed, it's really just some general ideas
and principles without a clear roadmap of
how to do it and to how to fund it.
So I support a lot of what's in it.
But you know, hopefully after the 2020 election,
Democrats will be able to actually start making
some headway on the components of it.
I agree.
My friend, God bless you.
You're the best.
Keep fighting and uh, uh, we love you brother.
All right, Jim, thank you.
Appreciate the phone call.
Thank you very much.
Hope to hear from you again.